>>> LE READ THIS CNN NE TO
NA NATION'JECTION TO
LAG N MO
THERE ARE COIEL Y YOUR CREMATEDO
PRLUNAR BURIAL OMPANIES THAT
SERVICES PLAN TO SEND DOZENS OF
SETS OF HUMAN REMAONO N
MOON INTO A BURIAL GROUND WOUL .
WHITE HOUSE TO
IN A STATEMENT THES JE TS THRE .
DEMOON.OUD
CELEBRATIO
PAACT OPPOSITE
ECRATION.ELRAG ME IS THE PRESID
THE
YOU FOG WITH ME.
TART WITH THE
EXPLANATION OF WHY SENDING THESE
HURE CAPWITH DNAO THE NAVAJO NAE
>> GOOD RN
THE TIME THAT YO G
ME.
ONE HAD
MEETING WITH THE
E PARTMENT
YESTERDAY.ONE PLAINED TO
S S MADE A
OMISE THFT OANIN S ON TO
TH T
MAKE SURATONSULT THIS
PRS THAT THEY  TNSTHT INTOOULD E
CONSULT US.
ONE OF TI AS
IS YOU HAVE A LO ILU AS
MOST OF THESMISSIONSN IT
UNDING THE
MILLIONS OF E
O HAT THT WERE
TT'R 20 YEARS AGO ARE
WHAT'S THE CULTURAL
E DLY DISAPPOINTING
DESECRATION IF THESE REMAINS
WERE TO TH?
>> FIRSTND
NACINE MANE  YEARSO BE UP FRONT.
I'M NOT A ONE OF THE THINGS THA
MOS IT'S
WE HAVE USED THE MOON AS A PLACE
ATVE LOOTOHUNDREF E SURE
WETO EXIST IS  THEY
WERE PART EREMONIES THAT
HAVE BEEOUH                THE
'90s, IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT WE
MAKE  T CONSULTCISULT
VADOAS NEVER BEEOPPOS
TION OOR SPA
IT TT THAT THE
IMPOONE LIFE IS SO
PLACE NO MATTEW  THEVERSE WE LO.
WE HAVE LOOKED FOR DEC N TECHNO
HAVE.
WE HAVEN'T FOUND PKE EARTH.
SOE' UNIQUE.E CREATEHERT
SH CE TOER
TH'S WASTHE
MEDICIENTHERE'S CEREEXISTHE NAVO
THOUSANDS OF YEARS THAT
YOHAEM CIRCLING
THE EART T
ABT A  TE NDE FEMALE
COUNTERPART OF THE SUN IN OUR
CULTE.
>> YOUAYT WET OFNG WITND NT OTR
COMMERCE DEPENOFFICIALS.
IVATE COMPANY AS WELL.
WI DELAYEDWAS ETING TOKIND OF S
AT I  THA, BUT THE LAUNCH IS ST.
WE ONLY ASK THAT NASOU
WE HAD A DISCUSSIOR INWIADMINISE
BUT INO  TALK ABOUT THAT INA IS
MISSIOVEN IF IS IV
COMPANY, MOST OF THESE  INTTH
COME WITH PARTNERING WITH
SA.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS I ASKNA IS
HAVE SIDLAINELINES THAT SAY WE
AMENTS PROMISE THAT EXISTS IN
THE UNITED STATES THATE'
M
T
I HOISE TOHA